we are down to the final three on
Dancing with the Stars and we were
backstage for all the surprises last
night and the most emotional moment of
the night GMA's ginger Zee going public
with the secret she just couldn't keep
it any longer
camera matheson has the story my parents
divorced when I was seven and I think it
affected my childhood a lot I needed to
control something so like I know what
I'll do I'll just not eat
10 to 14 was the the bulk of my anorexia
I don't think I even knew how how bad it
was at that time you know everybody's
gone through something and I think it's
a disease that you choose unfortunately
but it chooses a lot of people you know
a lot of young girls especially deal
with it
ginger used therapy to overcome her
childhood eating disorder but now she's
more obsessed with exercise in fact
since having her son Adrian almost 5
months ago the 35 year old moms dropped
all the baby weight on the show you
don't have to be stuck there there's a
whole life beyond your issue there and
and that's okay that you have it but you
can get through it
ginger and Vow are one of the final
three couples left standing last night's
double elimination sent perfect score
getting wanye and the beloved underdog
Antonio Brown home have you talked to
your kids how are they gonna feel about
this but it was extremely sad for losing
the competition obviously they're cited
for dad to come back to her there but
who will win the sentimental favorite is
Niall oh and he's also got that hot
shirtless guy thing going for him at
least that's what I've been told
last night the top model' performed
mindful he was really relying on touch
of the body and also dancing as one will
you give the people what they want and
let us see this man shirtless again
maybe I don't know yet I don't know
gingers got the mom slash GMA likability
but come on her secret weapon is val and
as for MMA fighter Paige Van Sant last
night sexy dance with Mark was awesome
and he says-- a pain but everyone just
wants to know if she'll have a showmance
with the guy with the man bun fellow
dancer Alan Burstyn after all the
chemistry on the show that you were
getting cosy at the after-party at
mixology 101 what exactly is that
chemist
who knows a girl does not get them down